في المقابله لم يجد منتخب الاكوادور ضالته
في قاره امريكا الجنوبيه حتى جاء تصفيات
مونديال 2002 عندما حقق انتصارا تاريخيا
على البرازيل بهدفين دون رد تقدم عليها في
الترتيب محتلا المركز الثاني قاطعا بطاقته
الاولى الى نهايه كاس العالم في ظهور
الاول
وحققت انجازها الوحيد في المونديال حتى
الان
عندما بلغ الدور 16 في مونديال المانيا
المانيا في ثلاثيه
في رضوان اقصائيه خسرت امام انجلترا بهدف
واحد سجله انا ذاك دافيد بكام في النسخه
المقبله من المونديال ستشارك اليكوادور
تحت اسرافي طاقم ارجنتيني بقياده جوستافو
الفارو والذي يدرب المنتخب
الرابع في تصفيه امريكا الجنوبيه بعد ان
رد الفيفا شكوى رفعتها تشيلي تدعي فيها
بتزوير اوراقي احاديث
قطر في المباراه الافتتاحيه على ملعب
البيت